All right.
Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome to this session on aging
micro and macro environments in tumor progression and therapy.
My name is Ashi Weriratne. I'm from Johns Hopkins, and
I'm here with my co-chair, Dr. Cosmo Cosimo.
We are going to hear a series of really excellent talks that were
picked by the committee from the abstracts.
We're going to hear about clonal hematopoiesis and immune
dysregulation, the gastric myeloid axis and
inflammation, melanoma reactivation,
age-stratified therapies, senolytics, and
glioblastoma, and think about what this means for clinical
translation and the future. You
should see somewhere, maybe I've clicked past it already, a QR code if
you don't want to ask your questions
out loud. But if you do ask your questions out loud, I ask that you please
go to the microphone, introduce yourself and your institute,
and we're going to take a couple of questions after each talk.
And then Cosmo is going to close out the session for us.
So if our first speaker would please come up.
This is Dr. Janghee Wu.
Start your slides. Okay.
Thank you.
I'm Janghee, the hematologist at Emory and Winship.
This is a result of many collaborators across the
globe in South Korea as well as Spain.
And
so this is my disclosure.
The story actually began with this study.
The CANTOS is the randomized phase three trial
testing IL-1 beta neutralizing antibody in the
cardiovascular disease patient with a
high sensitivity CRP is greater than two to test whether
the inhibition of IL-1 beta can actually change
cardiovascular outcomes, which was positive, and the
primary CV, cardiovascular endpoint was
met.
However, incidentally,
the treatment group with the IL-1
beta neutralizing antibody
also decreased the incidence of lung cancer, as
well as mortality and the total cancer mortality.
So this gave us an opportunity
to tease out,
first, whether the IL-1 beta actually
really prevent the lung cancer development, and
second, what is the mechanism?
So the next study we did
to interrogate in the context of the CANTOS, we wanted to
see whether the clonal hematopoiesis mutation
actually changed the outcome in the patient who received
canakinumab, the IL-1 beta, in terms of a
non-hematological malignancy incidence.
So we stratify the patient between the
CH mutation versus non-CH mutation, as if you look at on the
right side graph, where the patient who do not have a CH
mutation, basically placebo and canakinumab,
does not yield any change in terms of incidence of a
non-hematological malignancy. However, when we
stratify by the TET2 mutation, you see on the left, the
patient who received the placebo actually had a higher
incidence of a non-hematological malignancy in patients
without the clonal hematopoiesis mutation, whereas when they
are treated with canakinumab, the incidence
becoming significantly decreased.
So this gives us an opportunity to interrogate
what is the mechanism behind the clonal hematopoiesis mutation,
as well as the mechanism of IL-1 beta inhibition in this
context. So obviously, this paper is very well known.
The Swanton group in UK further demonstrate the
association of a clonal hematopoiesis in early stage of lung cancer.
So in previous canakinumab study, basically demonstrated
this clonal hematopoiesis mutation
presumably
prevent the development of lung cancer, which is early
stage of development of lung cancer.
However, this study also demonstrated a clonal hematopoiesis in
blood as well as tumor can change
the outcome of early stage of lung cancer.
So this study set the stage where we
can interrogate the mechanism as well as biology.
So we wanted to test first whether the clonal hematopoiesis
mutation, in this case, the TET2 mutations, can promote
the development of lung cancer. And the second hypothesis
we wanted to test whether the aging can play a role
in terms of developing the lung cancer, because
we know the IL-1 beta pathway or
the IL-1 pathway in general being
amplified in the TET2 mutated clonal hematopoiesis
as well as aging. So we set the
experiment to test this hypothesis to put
the
KP cells orthotopically
through the intratracheal injection in the
host with a TET2 mutated hematopoiesis in the
young aged mice, which was the 10 to 12 weeks,
whereas we also test the same
situation in the old aged mice. And
particularly, we are interested in both, whether the
TET2 is mediating change in the lung cancer development,
and age may play a role in the same context.
So the outcome, as shown hereWe
do see significant change in the lung cancer development,
particularly in the Tet2 deficient
hematopoiesis host in the aged
mice, which was depicted in the left, whereas the
right, we do not see any significant difference between the
wild-type host and the Tet2 heterozygous knockout or
the homozygous knockout, which indicates
not only Tet2 playing a role to enhance the tumor development
in the
lung environment,
but also the age plays a very significant role to
modulate the tumor development.
So now we wanted to
characterize the immune phenotype in the lung as well
as spleen to look at what is the immune
landscape change mediated by the Tet2 mutated
hematopoiesis. As you can see here, particularly in the tumor,
we do see the increased infiltration of
the CD45 cells, which was also demonstrated in the human.
But at the same time, we do see significant reduction of the NK cell
population in both spleen and tumor in the
Tet2 heterozygous knockout and homozygous knockout in the aged host,
as well as the infiltration of the
CD11b, the myeloid populations
dependent upon the Tet2 knockout.
So then we further interrogate the immune cell
population, particularly in the lymphocyte, the CD4 and CD8,
where we do see the upregulation of FoxP3
in the mice with a Tet2
heterozygous knockout as well as homozygous knockout.
And also those CD4 positive cells
have upregulation of IL-10, which is immunosuppressive
cytokine.
And then when we looked at the CD8 T cell population,
we do see the exhausted T cells marked by the
PD-1,
which was the Tet2
mutation-dependent way, as well as IL-10
expression was significantly upregulated in those mice.
Then the myeloid population, we do see the
significant increase of the myeloid population as
depicted earlier as well as this slide.
So basically, this data demonstrated Tet2
deficiency, in particular hematopoietic stem cell can
change immune landscape to provide a more
immunosuppressive microenvironment.
So then we wanted to interrogate a little more to see the
human phenotype, particularly in the patient with non-small cell lung
cancer,
working with
Dr. Woong-Young Park at the Samsung Medical Center.
We collected
the mononuclear cells from patients with non-small cell lung cancer, 59
patients, and then the
CH mutations was profiled to determine the individual
CH mutation by the next-generation
sequencing,
and then we teased out the single cell,
the transcriptomics in more than 200,000 single cells.
So here is the patient characteristics.
We included the 45 patients without clonal hematopoiesis mutation
and three and five, the NMTF Tet2 and the NMT3A mutated
patients in the blood.
So here is data where we include
those patients and then they characterize immune
landscape, and we do see the same trend, what we
see in the mouse tumor and spleen, which
basically demonstrate enhancement of the monocyte differentiation
as well as increase the CD8 and reduce the NK cell
population, particularly in the individual with Tet2 mutations,
which completely mirrored what we saw in the mouse
phenotype. And when we looked at the immune
functions signatures, the
monocyte population, we do see significant enrichment of MDSC
signatures in the Tet2 mutated clonal
hematopoiesis, as well as significant reduction of
cytotoxic signatures in NK cells from the
patient with a Tet2 mutated
the white blood cells. And then when we looked at the CD4 and
CD8 signatures, again, the same trend was
observed where the CD4 naive cells
significantly reduced, and then the more
differentiated phenotype along with the exhausted phenotype in the
CD8 cells was enriched in the patient with a
Tet2 mutated clonal hematopoiesis compared
to patients without the clonal hematopoiesis.
So this basically indicating in both mouse and
human,
the
Tet2 mutated clonal hematopoiesis can change immune
landscape where it can provide a more immunosuppressive
microenvironment characterized by the increased
CD4 TRX cells as well as CD8 TRX,
and the NK cell population also significantly decrease in
both human and mice.
Next then, we wanted to look at what is the
clinical outcome change mediated by the clonal
hematopoiesis. So we collaborated with the Spain
investigator led by Dr. Provencio and
Cruz
Bermudez, as well as Bel Lancera in
Spain. So we first looked at the
REALNADIM trial. So before this REALNADIM trial,
the Spanish investigator ran the
prospective trial with neoadjuvant chemoimmunotherapy
regimen in the early stage lung cancer,
where it demonstrated neoadjuvant chemoimmunotherapy
actually can significantly change the outcome of early
stage lung cancer. Now it's becoming standard of
care.So this REAL-NADIM
trial is the prospective trial where it's
actually collecting very robust biomarker studies
as well as
collecting the tumor and
the blood specimens. So now we first look at the blood
before neoadjuvant treatment is
initiated, and then we characterize the clonal hematopoiesis mutation in
blood first. Then we identified about 24%
of individuals in this trial carry the clonal
hematopoiesis mutations, where the most common mutations
include the NMTA3A and the TET2, which was consistent with the
previous data.
So then we
wanted to associate this clonal hematopoiesis status
with the clinical outcome. First, we looked at the
pathology response, which was not
significantly different between these two groups,
CH mutation positive and negative groups, as well as
progression-free survival was not different between these two groups.
So the left is the
unadjusted
Kaplan-Meier analysis, and the right, this is propensity matching
the
calculations where we synthetically include those
individual
with the same characteristics from the initial cohort
and demonstrate
the
no significant change of the progression-free survival, even
after adjustment.
But then the most strikingly,
the overall survival, whereas it significantly changed
after neoadjuvant chemoimmunotherapy
was given. So the patient who have CH
mutations before neoadjuvant chemotherapy
demonstrated a very prolonged overall survival,
whereas the patient without the clonal hematopoiesis mutations
demonstrate the inferior overall survival
even after adjusting the other covariables through
the propensity matching.
So we are still looking at this data, including
tumor-infiltrating clonal hematopoiesis, as well as the spatial
transcriptomics to look at more the underlying biology
mediated by the clonal hematopoiesis.
So in summary, the aged TET2 deficient clonal
hematopoiesis can promote lung cancer in
mice, and TET2 deficient clonal hematopoiesis
basically reshaped immune landscape to
promote
the
lung cancer. This effect mediated through both
innate and adaptive immunity. And obviously, every
individual CH mutations are different in terms of
reshaping microenvironment, and the CH mutation
may change the outcome of neoadjuvant
chemoimmunotherapy. So I would like to thank my lab,
particularly this study was led by Dr.
Eunyeong Kim and Yoo Han Byon, as well as Hyunwoo Park,
who is a very talented data scientist, and also
from our leadership, Dr. Ramalingam at the Winship through
thoracic oncology program, and our collaborators, Dr.
Park at the Samsung Medical Centers, and also Dr.
Provencio in Spain, and as well as Spain
investigators to
enroll those patients in REAL-NADIM study.
Thank you. Happy to take any questions.
So we do have time for questions.
Sorry about that. We do have time for questions.
I have a question.
Okay.
We're waiting for people.
So while we're waiting for people to go to the mic, that was lovely.
I do have a question about the fact that we see a lot of
increased clonal hematopoiesis with age, and it's been shown that
patients respond better to immune checkpoint therapy with age.
So how much of the CH that you're seeing in your patients
is associated with aging? And is there a subset of those
patients that has CH that are younger?
I don't know if that actually happens or not. I'd be curious to know.
Well, yes, I think this is a very active area of
research to tease out the response to immunotherapy
in the patient with the clonal hematopoiesis.
And the subsequent data from Dr. Chalmers at MD
Anderson also demonstrate a better response
to the immunotherapy in the patient with the TET2-mutated clonal
hematopoiesis. However, the mechanistic studies, probably
many of the investigators all around the world, is now actively working on to
understand those mechanisms. So I think
time will tell. This year or next year, we'll see the more
data to come out. And obviously,
from the
young patients with the clonal hematopoiesis mutation, it does occur.
And if we sequence deep enough,
if the age above 50, then we basically
universally see all the CH mutations.
So to point out, every
individual CH mutations are not necessarily the same.
So the particular TET2 is being
interrogated very
extensively, and other mutation, including the NMTA3A,
also being studied. So we got to really
look at each individual CH mutation to understand the
biology better.
Hi.
Great talk. So the data that you presented
at the start of the presentation around CHIP and initiation,
and the data you presented at the end of CHIP progression seemed to be potentially
quite different in terms of
what you think CHIP is doing. So can you summarize what you think CHIP is doing in
the context of initiation and progression?
Well, obviously our mouse data and also Kento's data,
it's to understand what's the role of clonal hematopoiesis
in the initiation of lung cancer. And
as you point out, the later data that we pointed out
here is neoadjuvant setting is obviously tumor already formed, and
then
we measure the clonal hematopoiesis mutation before starting
treatment. So the point is, I think
particularly the TET2 mutation can change immune
landscape no matter what. And the role
of the immune landscape change mediated by the clonal hematopoiesis
mutation will remain the same across the disease.
And,
obviously, CANOPE study from the
later stage of lung cancer did not reveal any
clinical benefit of IL-1 beta inhibition in the later stage
of lung cancer.
So
the immune landscape change mediated by the clonal hematopoiesis
remains, but the disease burden and the
long-term effect of clonal hematopoiesis after
treating with immunotherapy remains to be seen.
I think those areas where we are very actively
investigating for now.
Thanks.
Sure. Go ahead, but let's try to keep it succinct. Thank you.
Thank you, Gretel.
I was wondering, you have a rich data from these clinical trial results.
You were showing multiple time points for blood samples.
I was wondering if you had checked the development of new
CH after treatment, and if you have been able to differentiate
between just normal clonal hematopoiesis and these
tumor-infiltrating clonal hematopoiesis, and if this has an
impact.
That's exactly what we are doing.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Dr. Leppa. Please come up.
Good afternoon.
Yes, my name is Aino-Maija Leppa, and I will continue to talk about
clonal hematopoiesis in the completed TRACERx
cohort.
These are my disclosures.
So as you heard from the previous presentation, clonal hematopoiesis
or CHIP is an age-associated phenomenon in which hematopoietic
stem and progenitor cells acquire mutations and expand in the
blood. In non-small cell lung cancer, 30%
of patients have CHIP.
And out of these patients, in
over 40%, these mutant cells can also infiltrate the lung
tumors interacting with the cells in the lung tumor environment.
And we have termed this tumor-infiltrating clonal hematopoiesis or
TICH for short.
And importantly, as also shown already in the previous presentation,
patients with TICH, but not patients with blood-only CHIP, have
worse recurrence-free survival compared to patients without clonal
hematopoiesis.
And these findings are based on the first 400 patients, part of the
TRACERx study. And today, I want to talk about the different
ways we're trying to understand the longitudinal dynamics of CHIP
clones and how CHIP cells shape their surroundings in the
completed TRACERx study.
So quick word about TRACERx. So TRACERx is a multicenter prospective
observational study that tracks early-stage non-small cell lung
cancer tumor evolution over time.
And as part of TRACERx,
various patient material has been collected,
including paired blood samples, tumor tissue, and plasma
samples, all of which can be used to not only study
tumor evolution, but also clonal hematopoiesis.
And today, I want to focus on these three topics
here, starting with the prevalence and survival data in the completed
TRACERx study, followed by longitudinal
dynamics of the CHIP clones, and then ending with some molecular
data about the microenvironment and how the CHIP cells
shape their surroundings.
So in the completed TRACERx study, we have almost 800 patients with
baseline blood whole exome sequencing data that we can use
to identify these CHIP mutations.
And in this cohort,
33% of the patients carry these CHIP mutations, and out of
these, 43% have TICH.
And here on the right, you can see that the most commonly mutated genes
involve DNMT3A, TET2, and ASXL1 in
line with findings from others.
And here in gray, you can then also see the proportion of these mutations
that are only present in blood,
and then in red, the proportion of mutations that can, in addition, be
identified in the tumors.
And generally, the variable frequency of the CHIP mutations is
lower in the tumors, as seen here at the bottom of
the graph, compared to the variable frequency in the blood.
And this is consistent in all the assessed
genes.We then used
the ratio of this variable of frequency in the
tumor and blood to calculate a relative
tumor-infiltrating clone size. And what we observed
was that tumor-infiltrating clones containing TET2
and DNMT3A mutations tended to be bigger compared to
clones carrying CHIP mutations that are not
as commonly observed.
So this shows us that CHIP clones can infiltrate tumors, but they can
infiltrate tumors differently based on the affected gene.
And in the completed TRACERx study, we were able to again observe that indeed
patients with TISH, but not patients with blood-only CHIP, have worse
disease-free survival compared to patients without clonal hematopoiesis.
And now to assessing more detail
what the survival differences are
derived from, we wanted to look at the longitudinal dynamics of
these CHIP mutations. And for that, we took advantage of
the ctDNA framework that we have set up for the TRACERx study,
in which we have paired whole exome sequencing data from blood
and tumors that we then use to create patient-specific mutation panels.
And for a subset of patients, we then included also CHIP mutations in these
panels.
We then collected plasma samples longitudinally, allowing us to track
the CHIP mutations from the cell-free DNA.
And we have 37
patients in which we can now longitudinally assess the
evolution of these CHIP clones.
So using now the cell-free DNA data in these 37 patients, we were
specifically interested in understanding whether CHIP clones were
expanding or contracting independent of whether the tumor is
growing or shrinking.
So when we first looked at the overall trajectory of the change in
the variable of frequency over time of these CHIP mutations,
we could see that indeed the CHIP clones are expanding over the course of the
disease.
When we then split the cohort into patients who
received adjuvant treatment and patients who did not receive adjuvant treatment,
we could see that the CHIP clones were actually expanding
specifically in the patients who did not receive adjuvant
treatment. We then went back to the survival
data of the completed study. And as you can see
here on the left, when we split the patients again into those
who received or did not receive adjuvant treatment, that the
effect of TISH on survival was particularly prominent in an adjuvant
treatment-naive setting.
To better understand how CHIP cells now shape their surroundings,
we created a detailed overview of
the immune landscape of
the microenvironments
in patients with CHIP and without CHIP using two different
single-cell multi-omics approaches.
First, we used TargetSeq for simultaneous single-cell genotyping
and gene expression analysis to specifically look at differences in
TET2 mutant and TET2 wild type cells within the same patient.
And then to look at more global gene regulation differences between
patients that had TISH to patients that did not have clonal
hematopoiesis, we used DogmaSeq for simultaneous
chromatin accessibility, gene expression, and immunophenotype analysis.
And using the TargetSeq data, we could see that TET2 mutant cells were
enriched in myeloid cells, meaning monocytes, macrophages, and dendritic cells,
in line with what others have also seen.
And interestingly, we also observed an enrichment of TET2 mutant cells
in NK cells. And in contrast, T and B cells
consisted largely of TET2 wild type cells.
And while these TET2 mutant cells showed clear lineage skewing,
they did not seem to show prominent transcriptomic differences.
And this, in part, can already be seen in the UMAP on the left,
where you can see this intermixing of mutant and wild type TET2
cells with one another. So this led us to
hypothesize that maybe the microenvironment in
which the CHIP cells are residing is generally already altered
and is not restricted to only the
mutant cells.
To assess this hypothesis, we then went or turned into our second
single-cell cohort, and now comparing patients that had
TISH to patients that did not have clonal hematopoiesis.
And today, I will focus on some of the
transcriptomic findings of the immune subset of the cohort.
When we first looked at cell type abundance differences
in the immune subset, we could see an upregulation of gamma delta T
cells and cycling T cells, specifically in the patients that had
TISH compared to patients that did not have clonal hematopoiesis.
And this on the right, you can see that the gamma delta T cells were
particularly rich in the tumor tissue compared
to BPMCs, tumor adjacent normal tissue in the same
patient.
When we looked at more global changes, we observed an
upregulation of genes involved in the interferon response in the
patient that had TISH compared to patients that did not have clonal
hematopoiesis, in line with increased abundance of gamma delta T
cells.
So this suggests that the microenvironment with CHIP cells undergoes
immune remodeling, which is likely driven by the
presence of these CHIP cells.
So to summarize, I've shown you today that TISH drives worse
outcomes in non-small cell lung cancer, particularly in a
non-adjuvant setting.I've also shown you that CHIP mutations expand
over time in these patients who did not receive adjuvant systemic
therapy. And lastly, regarding the
microenvironment, it seems that TISH reshapes the tumor immune
microenvironment towards an inflammatory state that may potentiate this
disease progression.
And I would like to end by acknowledging
everybody involved in the study, everybody from the Swanton lab,
as well as the whole TRACERx consortium, as well as our funders, patients,
and their families. Thank you.
So while people are getting their questions together,
maybe I've missed it, but I'm wondering if you can comment on
how your findings
interplay with the changes that are happening in aging and
in age in general.
How age is affecting this?
Yeah.
Yes.
So while generally, CHIP is associated with aging.
Okay. So just directly because of the impact of CHIP with aging.
Exactly. So basically, there's a higher prevalence of CHIP in the aged
population.
Okay.
Thank you for the great talk. It looks
like the blood-only CH,
the outcome actually merged with the
TI-CH if you have a more follow-up.
So initially, the TRACERx
data in the last year demonstrate, as you said,
blood-only CH actually may not
necessarily be worse
than the TI-CH, tumor-infiltrating CH.
But if you look at your updated data, the blood-only CH,
their long-term outcome is actually merged with tumor-infiltrating
CH.
So whether that blood-only CH is
actually, the variant of frequency
increases, so then the tumor-infiltrating
CH
may be coming up later for those individuals with
initial blood-only CH and then becomes really
tumor-infiltrating CH, which led to similar
outcome eventually.
Yeah, that's a great question.
We have
the longitudinal data from the cell-free DNA, but also we
have paired data from diagnosis and metastasis.
So we could take a look at this, but we haven't assessed.
So the way we're calling TISH currently is based on the
diagnosis time point. So we're not using the recurrence progression
samples for that. But that's an excellent point.
Thank you.
Hi. Nice talk. This is Catherine from Yale.
I saw you have employed the single-cell multi-omics and also DomoIC into
the clonal hematopoiesis samples, including a healthy donor, which is a
really great supplement on the datasets.
So my question is, when you were doing the DomoIC sample,
you noticed that the enrichment in gamma delta T cells.
Is this the consequence for accumulation of
specific CHIP mutation gene, like DNMT3A or
TET2 specific, or it's general
population level, like you are in this CHIP, and then you develop this kind
of phenotype? Yes.
Yeah. Thank you. So our cohort consists of patients that
all of them have a TET2 mutation. One of them also has a
DNMT3A mutation, but we see it in all of the
patients.
How did you identify all genotype
your TET2 or DNMT3A mutations? Is it via DomoIC, or is it
outside, like a separate assay?
Yes. So Target Seek is the one where we have the genotyping
and the transcriptomic data from the same cell.
And in DomoIC, we are simply looking at the more global changes in the
microenvironment of the patients that have TISH and do not
have clonal hematopoiesis. So we cannot genotype the mutations
in that specific cohort.
Okay, cool. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Okay, our next speaker is Shuang Li,
who will be talking about TFF2 deficiency amplifies
IL-1 beta-driven inflammation and promotes
aging-associated gastric tumor progression.
That's a good
way to do it.
Okay, thanks. I should have typed in earlier.
What?
I should have known.
Good afternoon. I'm Shuang Li.
Thank you for the introduction, and it's my
honor to present our study about the TFF2
deficiency amplifies IL-1 beta-driven inflammation
and promotes aging-associated gastric tumor progression.
This study is supported by Tonix Pharmaceuticals, and several
co-authors are affiliated with the company.
As we know, aging is a major risk factor for gastric cancer,
but the underlying mechanism remain poorly defined.
One of the key feature of aging is the chronic low-grade
inflammation, which is known as inflammaging.
During the inflammaging, the immune system undergoes
a significant remodeling, including the myeloid
scarring in bone marrow, expansion of
MDSCs, and increased pro-inflammatory
cytokines.
TFF2 is a member of the trefoil factor family,
primarily expressed in gastric mucous neck cells, and
plays key roles in epithelial protection and immune
regulation.
In our previous work, we fused TIF2 with murine serum
albumin to develop a peptide
TIF2-MSA with enhanced stability.
TIF2-MSA can function as a partial agonist of
CXCR4 and synergizes with PD1
blockade to suppress gastric tumor progression.
However, whether TIF2 regulates age-associated
inflammation and the tumor progression remains unknown.
So here are the key findings from our study.
First, we identify that TIF2-positive epithelial
cells are reduced in the aged stomach.
We compare young mice at three months old and
aged mice at 18 months old.
In our previous study, TIF2 marks both the
mucus neck cell and the progenitor population.
So on the left, we found that the TIF2-positive cell
decline in the aged stomach, both in the corpus and
in the antrum.
And on the right, we found that in the single-cell
RNA seq data, the progenitor score is decreased in
the aged stomach.
And we also find that the TIF2 probe
labeled progenitor cells are decreased in the aged stomach.
Based on the loss of TIF2-positive cells, we
wanted to know whether the TIF2 reduction is
global in the aged
mice. So we find that in the single
RNA cell data, the TIF2 expression is reduced in
the aged stomach. And the TIF2 protein is also
declined in both the stomach and in the serum.
However, this change seems to be a stomach
specific change, as we do not see a similar change
in the duodenum or the pancreas.
Next, we want to know how the aging changes the
immune microenvironment.
We found that the PMN MDSCs accumulate in
both the stomach and in the blood.
And there is a myeloid bias in the bone marrow, as
reflected by the GMP population
upregulation.
And we also see in the elevated inflammatory cytokines such
as IL6 and the TNF alpha
in the stomach,
which shows gastric and systemic
inflammaging during the aging.
To investigate the causal link between TIF2 loss
and the MDSC expansion, we use the
TIF2 heterozygous and knockout mice.
We found that
PMN MDSCs accumulate in both the stomach
and in the blood.
Also, we see that the CD8 positive T cells are reduced,
indicating a immunosuppressive phenotype, mirrors
what we see in the aged mice.
Next, we want to know whether restoring TIF2 can reverse
this MDSC expansion and inflammaging.
We use TIF2-MSA in this experiment, and we found that
the TIF2-MSA can reduce PMN MDSC
accumulation and partially restore circulating CD8
T cells.
And it can also reverse myeloid bias in the bone marrow,
as reflected by the MPP3 and the GMP
upregulation in the bone marrow.
And this suggests that restoring TIF2 can
reverse the PMN MDSC expansion and the systemic
inflammaging.
So next, we want to know how the aging affects the tumor
progression. To address this, we use two complementary
gastric tumor models. One is the ACKP syngenic
orthotopic model, and one is the MNU-induced
gastric cancer model.
We found that in the ACKP model, aging enhances the
tumor growth and the tumor burden, and also causes a shorter
overall survival.
And in the MNU model, we see a consistent
data.
And then we investigate the tumor
microenvironment. We found that in
the aged tumor microenvironment, PMN MDSCs are
expanded and exhibit elevated IL1
beta expression. PDGF alpha
positive, IL1R1 positive CAFs are also
elevated in the aged gastric tumors.
This suggests that the PMN MDSCs derived IL1
beta interacted with the IL1R1 positive CAFs in the tumor
microenvironment and contributes to
immunosuppressive and the tumor promoting niche.
And in order to know whether restoring TIF2 could limit
this age-associated tumor progression, we use
TIF2-MSA as a pretreatment.
We found that pretreatment with TIF2-MSA can reduce
the tumor growth and burden in the aged mice.
And the effect of TIF2-MSA is consistent across
ACKP orthotopic model and the
MNU-induced models.
And this supports that the TIF2-MSA could
limit the age-associated tumor progression.
And then we look at the tumor microenvironment.
We found that the TIF2-MSA could reduce the PMN
MDSCs and the PDGF
alphaPositive IL1RN, positive CAFs
in the aged tumors, and the CD8 T cells
are increased following TIF2 restoration.
This suggests that the TIF2 MSA could reverse the
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment.
In summary, we propose that aging-associated
loss of TIF2 drives systemic inflammaging,
including MDSC expansion in stomach and in
circulation, myeloid base in the bone marrow,
and inflammatory cytokines elevation in the circulation.
The MDSC-derived IL1B activates
IL1RN positive CAFs and establish a
tumor-promoting microenvironment.
Restoring TIF2 signaling limits this cascade
and attenuates tumor progression.
And I like to thank my PI, Dr. Timothy Wong, for
his guidance and support. I like to thank
all of my lab members and our collaborators,
and thank you for your
attention.
I have a question. Nice talk.
Thank you.
So I'm curious about the MSA fusion to the
TFF2. Do you know if that affects TFF2 in any way?
Is that
just tagging it with the MSA, does it get taken up into the cells in a different
way, or can you comment on that fusion?
I think we've tested
the TIF2 MSA on how it will
function different from the normal TIF2.
I think it doesn't change the way that TIF2 acts on the
myeloid cells or in the circulation, but it just
will prolong the stability and prolong the
TIF2 MSA
persistence in the circulation and in the body. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks very much.
All right, our next speaker is
Kelly Coutant, The Role of Aging in Immune-Mediated
Reactivation from Metastatic Dormancy.
So
good afternoon, everyone. So first of all, I would like to thanks all the
AACR committee to gave me the opportunity to present my postdoc
results in Dr. Mitchesin lab.
I have no disclosure to declare.
So among the different factors associated to cancer development,
aging correspond to one of them. And as illustrated in front of you,
there is a graph representing the incidence of different cancer in function
of age. And we can see that incidence and progression will
increase with aging. But we wanted to see if we will obtain the
same similar trend but apply to skin melanoma.
And as you can see, we will obtain an increase of the
incidence in younger patient, followed by a peak at the
median age,
65 years old for skin melanoma patient.
And surprisingly, we'll have a decrease of this number in geriatric
population. So we wanted to see if we will obtain something
similar but apply to a marine model.
And the problem is the population is aging.
It has been estimated that in 2050,
21.5% of total worldwide population will be aged more
than 60 years old.
And concerning the burden of cutaneous melanoma, it will increase by
48% within 15 years. So all this
data suggest us to look at the impact of aging in skin
melanoma.
So skin melanoma is the fifth most common cancer in the USA,
derived from the malignant transformation of melanocytes.
And while the surgical resection of primary tumor will increase the survival rates,
the metastatic spread to organs such as the liver will dramatically worsen
prognosis because unfortunately less than 50% of
patient respond to immunotherapy as PD-1 and CTLA-4.
So we wanted to look at different metastatic colonization model in Dr.
Mitchesven lab, and we were using tail vein injection to
obtain lung metastasis. And recently we are using
hydrodynamic tail vein or HGTB to obtain
metastasis in the liver.
So when I joined Mitch's lab two years ago, my first experiment was to
inject melanoma cell by tail vein or HGTB in different age of
mice. And after three weeks, I collected this organ,
and I was able to show that in the middle age condition, we obtain an
increase of the liver metastasis or growth compared to the young
condition.
And in the geriatric group, we observe a decrease of the liver
metastasis, which confirms the previous clinical results,
or this observation were confirmed by quantification of
metastasis.
So because of this increase in the middle age condition
only of the liver metastasis, we wanted to understand what could be at the
origin of this increase. And our hypothesis was that
a potential dysregulation of human cell type could increase the liver
metastasis only in the age condition.
So we designed a lymphoid and myeloid panel to look at all different human cell
type in our murine model, and we found that in the age
condition only, we will observe a decrease of
gamma delta T-cells compared to the young and geriatric condition.
So gamma delta T-cells correspond to a rare subset of T lymphocytes.
It's a first responder in human body, and it's a
bridge between innate and adaptative immunity.And its
particularity, it does not need major histocompatibility complex to
recognize pathogen.
Among the different subpopulation of gamma delta T cell, which are very
different between human and mouse,
it has been published that generally its skin melanoma gamma
delta T cell, which produce interleukin 70 A, will be
associated to antitumor role compared to the production of interferon
gamma by gamma delta T cells, will be associated to protumoral
role. So we wanted to see if we will obtain something similar in the
H melanoma metastasis, because currently it has not been properly studied.
So my hypothesis was the age could decrease the gamma delta T cell number,
and it will promote the increased progression of skin melanoma.
And in first, I wanted to investigate the role of gamma delta T cells
in regulation of age primary and metastatic growth.
So I'm working in close collaboration with Dr.
David Weiss, who is an expert in the gamma delta T cell field.
And we borrow some of these mice, where when you treat them with diphtheria
toxin, it will deplete the gamma delta T cells in the murine model.
So we injected our melanoma cells by intradermal tail vein or
AGTV, and after three weeks, we collected the
organ to analyze them by flow cytometry.
And we were able to show that after three weeks, which is the time we needed to
obtain liver metastasis, that our gamma delta T cell depletion
model decreased the gamma delta T cell expression compared to
the white tap mice.
And we validate this into the spleen, but also the lung and the liver.
So all this data show we are using efficient model
to deplete the gamma delta T cells.
So we decided in first to look at the primary tumor model.
So we injected melanoma cells in the flank of the mice, and we show that when
we deplete the gamma delta T cells, we will
decrease the primary tumor volume compared to the white tap
condition. But despite this very slow growth of the primary
tumor, the mice were starting to die.
So we decided to sacrifice them, and we observed they presented
huge metastasis in the liver. So we repeated this
experiment, but this time by injected melanoma cell by
AGTV to obtain liver metastasis. And we show this
time that when we deplete gamma delta T cells, we will increase the liver
metastasis compared to the white tap condition.
So these results are totally in opposition to the primary tumor
model, showing us it's really something dependent on the metastatic
sites.
So we decided to do an experiment with FE
mice where we inject melanoma cells by AGTV,
and we observe in the age microenvironments, it will increase the
liver metastasis, and it was associated to a decrease of
the gamma delta T cell expression.
And if we look at some markers of gamma delta T cells, we can
see that gamma delta T cells in the age environments increase the
expression of PD-1 exhaustion marker,
but also increase Vgamma 1. Vgamma 1, it's
a subpopulation of gamma delta T cell, which is associated to
protumoral role. And we observe a significant
decrease of Vgamma 6. Vgamma 6, which is
a subpopulation of gamma delta T
cells associated to antitumor role.
So these results show us that the age
environments promote the immunosuppressive role of gamma delta T cells.
So,
in summary, at this point, we show that age microenvironments
increase liver metastasis, which decrease the gamma delta T
cells in opposition to the geriatric condition where we will obtain
a decrease of liver metastasis, but an increase of the gamma
delta T cells. So my next step was to look at if we deplete
gamma delta T cells in our geriatric condition where we got a
higher expression of a gamma delta T cell, could we reverse
the progression of liver metastasis?
So because of the gamma delta T cell depletion
murine model were aging, we decided to took geriatric mice
where we injected melanoma cell by AGTV, and we submitted these
mice to IgG control injection or to a gamma delta T cell
antibody to deplete the gamma delta T cell in our geriatric mice.
And after three weeks, we show that this gamma delta T cell depletion,
we observe an increase of the liver metastasis compared to the
IgG control, and this observation were confirmed by
quantification of metastasis.
So we show at this point that the age microenvironments decrease the gamma delta
T cells, which promote the liver metastasis or growth.
But we wanted to understand what could be at the origin of this decline of
gamma delta T cells in the age microenvironments.
Our hypothesis focus on the potential increase of POSN1,
because during his postdoc, Mitch published a paper showing
that POSN1 can increase in the age metastatic tumor
microenvironments, and it has also been published that POSN1
increase the immunosuppressive myeloid cells.
So we decided to look at the role of POSN1 in a potential role
in the age microenvironments.
So with John Pasamante, who is a master student in Mitch
lab, we overexpress POSN1 in our melanoma cells,
and we show that when we overexpress POSN1, it will increase
lung and liver metastasis, but it was also associated
to a decrease of the gamma delta T cells.
And when we look at in literature, we
found a paper showing that the myeloid-derived suppressor cells or
MDSC, which are protumor immunosuppressive cells,
can decrease the activity of gamma delta T cells in
human.So we decided to look at the expression
of this MDSC in our last experiment, and we show
that when we overexpress POSN1, it will increase the
PMN MDSC cells.
So we look back in our experiment where we compare the different
age, and we found that in the aged environment,
we obtain an increase of these MDSC cells compared to the
young and geriatric group.
So we were able to show that the aged microenvironments increase POSN1,
which increase PMN MDSC.
It will decrease the expression of gamma delta T cells,
which will promote the liver metastasis growth.
So I would like to thank all Dr. Mitch's lab, specifically
Mitch, for all his huge help for my postdoc.
I would like to thank the collaborators, Dr.
David Weiss, Dr. Yingying Geng,
Dr. George Xu, Dr. Sven Miller, and the facilities, the funding,
and the award. And I would like just quickly thank the AACR Margaret Foti
Foundation and the Cancer Signaling Microenvironment Award, which permit
me to present my result
in front of you today. Thank you.
Thank you very much. I just have a quick question, and maybe I missed
this.
So the MDSCs
regulating the subset of T cells that you were looking at,
do you know why that's only happening in the aged?
So we don't know exactly. We just, for another project,
we show that when we, in the aged environments, it will
increase arginase one, which is secreted by
MDSC cells. And we hypothesis that
this production of arginase one will participate
to MDSC cells and interact also with
POSN1. But it will be my next experiment.
We perform an experiment where we
add recombinant POSN1 on melanoma cells, and we want to see if it will
secrete some
chemokine, which will attract MDSC cells.
Thank you.
Does your mic work? Maybe yours.
No. None of them.
Oh. The mics...
Okay, now it's working.
That was beautiful.
I wonder whether you have considered or if there is a
possibility to use gamma delta T cells therapy
for middle-age people.
Have you thought of that?
Yeah. So we have two
idea of therapy. First one, we are working in collaboration with Dr.
George Xu, who has established a model with car gamma delta T
cells. And I'm also optimizing
another therapy based on adoptive gamma delta T cell transfer,
which corresponds to isolate some gamma delta T cell
from young patient to reinject them into
aged patient with metastasis.
Hi. Frances Torrell from the University of Manchester. Really nice talk.
Really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
Really interesting, these differences between the middle age and geriatric mice.
I just wondered, given these differences in immune aging
between the sexes and some of those differences have been seen in melanoma as well,
have you looked to see whether you see the same effects in...
I think you had mentioned your model is in male mice, right?
Have you looked to see whether you see the same in humans?
In humanized mice, you mean? Sorry.
No,
between the different sexes. So if you looked male
versus female.
Ah, yeah, sorry.
Any changes.
So we are not working directly on this part of project, but we are
working in collaboration with Dr.
Yas Shaba, who is an expert in the sex disparity in melanoma.
And we show, for example, for gamma delta T cell in female, it will have a
different
result compared to
in a male. For example, with aging, gamma delta T cell
will increase in female compared to the male where we
observe gamma delta T cell will decrease.
And we've done some experiment with female, but where we were
doing the gamma delta T cell depletion model in female, the mice were starting
to die. So it's something we are currently trying to
develop with Dr. Yas Shaba to have more answer.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
This is Ada from Miley. I'm really curious for the upregulation
of POSN1 and the decrease in gamma delta T cells in the
middle-age mice. Have you looked at why
this POSN1 was suddenly upregulated?
Is it a developmental process or it's something that just happens in
mice? And how does this translate to humans?
Does the same phenomenon happen?
Thank you for your question. So during his postdoc, Mitch published
a paper showing that melanoma cells, when they will be
reactivated, there is
inhibits
one of the marker of dormancy, and they will activate the
reactivation marker, which is Mur.
And when they will be reactivated, melanoma cells will secrete
POSN1. So currently to really understand the mechanism
related to relation with POSN1 and melanoma cells,
we just received some results about the
RNA sequencing of melanoma cells similar to
recombinant POSN1. So maybe at the next meeting, I could give you more
answer about the relation. But yeah.
Thank you.
Hi. I just wanted to comment on your experiment specifically
with the geriatric mice, where you depleted the gamma delta T
cells. I was wondering if you were considering doing another study on the younger
mice, which showed some similarities to the geriatric mice, and maybe
thinking of depleting the gamma T cells in that and seeing how that might-
You mean to do the same experiment but apply to young mice?
Yes.
Yeah. So I done this experiment
first, but I would like to repeat it
with a different melanoma cell type.
Because I've done it in first with just healthy condition to see
how the depletion of gamma delta T cell will
involve a dysregulation in young or aged microenvironments.
And I just need to do it with the injection of melanoma
cells. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Oh, sorry.
There is an-
The lights were blinding.
Leave the light.
Hi. My name is Ajinkya. I'm from Mass General.
Great talk, by the way.
Thank you.
Quick question related to myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
By any chance, have you seen them, like senescent myeloid-derived suppressor
cells causing the inhibition of your gamma delta T cells?
And would you use the senolytics to clear them off and
see if the population rises?
So we haven't directly
look at the interaction between MDSC cells and gamma delta
T cells. It's something we would like to
do later,
because we need to isolate MDSC cells and do
co-culture with gamma delta T cells to look at what impact it could have.
But yeah, it's something we would like to do later. Thank you.
Okay. Now, thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right. Our next speaker is M Spacek.
The title of the talk is Age Stratified Therapeutic Strategies
Targeting Tumor Cell Subclones That Drive Chemoresistance and Immunosuppression
in Triple Negative Breast Cancer.
Hi, everyone. Thank you for coming today.
I'm going to be talking about how aging impacts triple negative breast cancer,
disease progression, and therapeutic responses, and then also how we were able to
use a new DNA barcoding system to
identify a subset of cells within these tumors that is resistant to
chemotherapy, that we're then able to target to try to improve
outcomes with age.
So this has already been discussed numerous times, but age is the biggest risk
factor for developing most forms of cancer.
To the effect that over 60% of new cancer cases each year are in
patients over 65 years old. The problem, however, is
that less than 25% of patients that are enrolled in clinical trials are in that
age range. This is also compounded by the fact that the majority of
preclinical models are performed in young animals, meaning that
from the preclinical through clinical stages, we're not accurately reflecting the
patient populations most suffering from these conditions, as almost everyone else
here today has been talking about.
And in the case of triple negative breast cancer, we have seen that
this is actually a molecularly distinct disease with age.
We've looked at a number of different data sets, but one example is looking at the
Metabric data set and stratifying patients by under 40 versus over
65. We see that there's a lot of differentially expressed genes, and a lot
of these programs are related to immune responses.
Which also makes sense because with age, it's also very well known
that immune function changes.
We also recently published a single cell analysis also confirming
these results at the single cell level.
So I encourage anyone to dig through that data set as well.
We also found striking differences between triple negative versus hormone
receptor positive disease.
Specifically with the case of triple negative breast cancer, we know that this is a
very highly aggressive disease. It's the most aggressive subtype of breast
cancer,
and it lacks any targeted therapies.
Meaning that the standard of care now is typically a combination of
chemotherapy with an immunotherapy.
However, these treatments often lead to resistance,
particularly to chemotherapy in the older population.
And also the older populations don't tolerate chemotherapy quite as
well. So we think that we need to start, one, identifying new age
stratified treatment strategies to better treat patients of all ages,
but also attempt to remove toxic chemotherapy from patients that don't
tolerate it as well.
So to start to pre-clinically analyze this and dig into the
role of aging and triple negative breast cancer, we're using the FVB
strain of mice. So this is a fully immunocompetent strain of mice,
and we start with them around eight to 10 weeks old, as our young cohort.
And then we also age mice in-house until they're around 14 months old.
And we have profiled the peripheral blood of these mice at these ages
from cancer-free mice, and we see that they have an expansion of neutrophils,
shifting from lymphocyte to monocyte populations, reductions in different
T cell subsets within the blood, all hallmarks of healthy
immune aging. And so we think that our model accurately reflects
patients that are over 60 years old in this older cohort.
But importantly also, this strain of mice does start to develop
some comorbidities after
one year, year and a half old. And so at this time point, our mice
don't exhibit noticeable other comorbidities.
So we think that most of the responses that we see are due to immune aging.
And so we then took these mice and injected them with
syngeneic Met1 triple negative breast cancer cells.
And then we treated the mice with either paclitaxel chemotherapy
or combination with anti-PD-L1 immunotherapy.
And what we see immediately, and we've published on this before, is
thatThe tumor growth is much more aggressive in the younger
mice, so the disease is just more aggressive in younger.
But you can see that when we apply monotherapy and combination therapy,
the young mice really get a nice stratification of responses to treatment, where
the combination therapy really outperforms either monotherapy.
But in the aged mice on the right, they respond a little bit to treatment, but they
don't get any additional benefit of combination therapy over monotherapy.
And if we plot the change in tumor volume from these treatments relative to the
age-matched control,
we see that the young mice really get a robust response to treatment,
and particularly, a significant benefit of combination therapy
over monotherapy alone. However, the older mice on the far right
do not have any significant benefit of combination over monotherapy.
And they just overall don't respond nearly as well to treatments.
So again, highlighting that with these older mice, we potentially need alternative
treatment strategies and maybe ones that don't rely on chemotherapy.
So we next wanted to molecularly understand a little bit what was going on here,
and so we performed bulk RNA sequencing on those same tumors and then performed
gene set enrichment analysis for hallmark pathways here, where everything here
in red is significantly enriched in a treatment versus its
age-matched control.
And in the young mice, we see that there's a lot of those immune response
programs are enriched with treatment.
And that potentially explains then why the younger mice were able to have a more
robust response to treatment. However, the older mice, you can see on
the right here, don't have nearly as
robust of a molecular reprogramming and molecular response
as the younger mice do to treatment, and particularly the paclitaxel group that
I've highlighted here in green has almost no molecular change.
And these are only some of the pathways that we've seen, but it's almost as if
the paclitaxel just is not really doing as much in these older mice.
Again, adding to the fact that we need alternatives to
paclitaxel.
So another aspect of this study is that all of the cells that I used
in this preclinical model contain DNA barcodes.
So, I will only summarize this briefly, this method, and
you can check out our paper if you want to see more details of how we do this.
But in short, we single-cell clone
heterogeneous population and isolate single-cell clones and
preserve them independently. And then we infect each of those with its own
unique DNA barcode. So that way we have
here, in this case, we have 31 clones of sub-cloned cells that each
have their own unique DNA barcode.
So we can track them longitudinally in vivo, in vitro.
We can also
profile those cells against each other to see molecularly
at the protein level how they might be distinct from each other.
We can also, though, take these cells and recombine them in any way that we want to
make custom tumors.
And all of this is detectable by qPCR.
So we found with this that when we treat either young or aged mice with
paclitaxel, there's only one clone that significantly increases after
paclitaxel treatment.
And we call it barcode 25, but the name doesn't really matter.
But it increases in both young and aged mice with chemotherapy treatment.
And when we implant these cells as a clonal tumor into mice and
then treat with paclitaxel, they still maintain complete resistance to
paclitaxel.
So we then
took these cells and mixed them, and I generated a couple of custom
pools that either contained the most dominant clones within the tumors,
plus or minus that chemo-resistant clone, which is in the blue bars.
And when we do this, we see that even a small amount of this clone, and actually in
these tumors, it only takes up less than 5% of the tumor,
it drives an increase in PD-L1 expression, in interferon gamma expression,
the immune recruitment factor CXCL10, but it also increases
EMT factors such as vimentin and immunosuppression factors such as
Ebi3.
So we took these chemo-resistant cells, and then we wanted to see if we could
actually target them
therapeutically. And so we did a drug screen using an FDA-approved
compound library,
and we actually found that the top hits, most of the top hits were
all pan-HDAC inhibitors or histone deacetylase inhibitors, with the
top hit in this screen being panobinostat.
So
we then just wanted to jump right to the end and see if we combine
this HDAC inhibitor with an immunotherapy, how does that
perform with age?
And we actually strikingly see that the combination of panobinostat and
anti-PD-L1, particularly in the aged mice, has a
significant benefit on increasing lifespan of these mice in that
pink line. Whereas the young mice on combination treatment are in the green
line. They still get a benefit over monotherapy,
but it's not nearly as striking as in those older mice.
However, young mice, since they still can tolerate the chemotherapy a little bit
better than the older mice,
we then did take some of these animals, and only in the young mice,
performed a triple combination with anti-PD-L1, panobinostat, and paclitaxel,
and we get almost complete tumor control with this triple
combination regimen.
And so just to quickly summarize all the data here, we know that age is the biggest
risk factor for developing most forms of cancer, including breast cancer,
but the toxic chemotherapy is really not that well-tolerated by the older patients.
But with this DNA barcoding system, we can identify a chemo-resistant population
and target it.
So we think that maybe HDAC inhibition could be a potential modality from
which we can build age-stratified treatment options in the future.
This comes with a little bit of a caveat, though, in that HDAC inhibitors,
pan-HDAC inhibitors, have been tested as monotherapies,
but they are met with some clinical toxicities.However, we think that
combination therapies may be able to lower those toxicities.
And as has been mentioned in several other sessions throughout the conference this
year, there are now starting to become some next-generation selective
HDAC inhibitors that could potentially further lower toxicities.
So with that, I'll acknowledge a whole host of people that made all of
this work possible, and I'll take any questions.
Okay.
If any questions for Milos, please come up to the microphones. I'll start.
I guess I have a question. Very nice talk.
And I'm wondering, so for other disease models that
take age into
consideration because the patients are mainly in the older
populations, I'm wondering about what you're finding.
Do you think any of it could be transferable to other cancer types?
So it's actually very tricky, but almost exciting because we've
seen very different responses with aging in different
cancer types. So melanomas respond much better with age to
immunotherapies. We do have some colleagues also that have looked at
HER2-positive disease, and it almost responds a little bit opposite
of triple-negative breast cancer.
So there's definitely
context-specific differences in how age impacts
disease progression and therapeutic responses.
So it's kind of an exciting time to learn how all of those are different, but
then what aspects might be conserved.
Thank you.
Great talk. I have a question regarding your methodology
in including and excluding BC25-
Yes
... I think. The name doesn't matter, I guess.
Yeah.
So, do you also see with the presence of the
BC25, like when the tumors
are bigger, does it also protect the other clones
surviving in the bigger, or this is the only surviving
clone
because it's chemo-resistant?
So at this time point in vivo, other clones are
certainly present, but this is the only clone that seems to expand.
If it's
actually growing in response to the chemo or if it's just purely just
not dying,
we're still teasing that out a little bit.
But if we take the whole heterogeneous pool of cells and put it in
a dish, I didn't show this aspect of it, but if we put those cells in a dish and
just continuously treat them with paclitaxel, after about three
weeks, it becomes entirely clonal for just barcode 25.
So all of the other cells do die out, and these cells maintain
resistance.
All right. Thank you very much.
Thanks.
Okay, our next speaker is Manon Penco-Campillo.
Title of the talk is "Age-Dependent Neuroimmune Changes in
Glioblastoma Shape Therapeutic Response and Reveal
Senescent Microglia as a Targetable Vulnerability."
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Manon Penco-Campillo, a postdoctoral fellow
in Dr. Wainwright laboratory in Loyola University of Chicago.
And today I present my work on how age-dependent neuroimmune changes
in glioblastoma shape therapeutic response and reveal senescent
microglia as a targetable vulnerability.
I have no disclosure.
So first, a short introduction on glioblastoma.
Glioblastoma is the most common aggressive malignant brain tumor in adults,
representing 50% to 60% of central nervous system tumor,
with 22,000 new cases and approximately 50,000
deaths per year in the United States.
The median age at the diagnosis is comprising between
68 and 70 years old.
The standard of care has not changed since 2005 and
relies on maximum resection, radiotherapy,
concurrent temozolomide, followed by adjuvant temozolomide.
Despite this aggressive treatment, outcomes remain poor, with a median
overall survival about 14.6 months.
And all clinical trial with immunotherapy have
failed. So overall, glioblastoma remains one of the most
challenging cancer to treat, with minimal therapeutic progress over
the two last decades.
Here, we first showed and confirmed the poor overall survival
in older glioblastoma patients. For that, SEER
database was analyzed across all age group for overall
survival. And as you can see, patient in the range
18, 44 years old present a median overall survival of
1.58 years, and this survival decreases
with progressive aging until it reaches 0.25 years
for patient over 75 years old. So this
data indicate that increased age is a negative prognostic factor
for glioblastoma patient.
Then we wanted to know where this negative aging effect comes from.
In this study, the author
look at the tumor for being associated with age or
not. So they took the tumor from patient, and they looked on
cancers including glioblastoma.
And for glioblastoma, the RNA sequencing does not reveal any
significant changing in term of gene expression when comparing younger
versus older glioblastoma patient.
So that tumor doesn't reflect their chronological age.
And we confirm this data with a single-cell RNA sequencing.
So based on this data, we hypothesized that the
major age-dependent changing in term of survival
does not come from inside of the tumor but comes from outside of the tumor
mass.To test this hypothesis, we
used the MRI guided biopsies to identify different
tumor region, different brain region.
So as you can see here, we identified the tumor core versus the
peritumoral region, which is right around the tumor.
And as we can see, the glioblastoma patient tumor core and
peritumoral brain have a distinct cellular composition.
For example, the peritumoral show more oligodendrocyte and
microglia as compared to the tumor core that present more malignant
cells.
Then we decided to focus on senescence because we know that senescence
increase with progressive aging and might play a role in
the different survival between younger versus older glioblastoma
patient.
So here we showed the mean senescence score, which is an
accumulation of different senescence gene signatures.
And we compared two different group of age for
glioblastoma patient, younger than 64 years old versus
older than 65 years old. For those two different region that we
saw right before, the peritumoral region and the tumor core.
So we saw that for glioblastoma patient,
the peritumoral tissue is enriched for
senescent cells with a P value of 0.1,
and especially in the microglia cell type.
So to confirm this increase of senescence that
we saw in human patient in mice, we used two months
old for young versus 24 months old for old
C57 black 6 mice that are intracranially injected
with glioblastoma cells SB28. To quantify the
senescence, I perform flow cytometric quantification of cells that are
positive for the beta-galactosidase, the marker of senescence.
And I compare those two different region, which is the extraterminal brain
versus the intratumoral brain.
So we saw that senescence is significantly
increased in the older adult as compared to the younger mice,
in blue with glioblastoma.
Then,
to see if this accumulation of senescence in older
mice can be reduced, the young and old mice were treated with
or without the brain radiotherapy.
A combination of immunotherapy, which is anti PD-1 antibody and
IDO enzyme inhibitors
with or without the senolytics, dasatinib and
quercetin called TQ in blue here.
So for young mice, the treatment didn't change the percentage
of, beta-galactosidase or senescence cells in the brain or in
the tumor. But for old mice, the senolytics decreased
the beta-galactosidase cells selectively in the extraterminal
brain, but not inside of the tumor.
To go deeper in the analysis, we wanted to know which brain resident
cells were senescence. For that, we performed the same experiment
with young and old mice that were intracranially injected with
SB28.
And we quantified the senescence with the beta-galactosidase on
different brain resident cells. And we saw that the
senolytics decreased the percentage of microglia
beta-galactosidase cells in the older adult
brain with a brain tumor. And we confirmed this result with
another in vivo modeling system, which is the Inc-ATAC mice model.
So then we wanted to know if the senolytic can have
an action on the survival. So for that, the
young and old mice were treated with the combination of
radiation and immunotherapy or the combination with radiation
immunotherapy with the senolytics.
So for the young mice, the radiation and
immunotherapy significantly improved the overall survival as compared
to the control or the senolytics alone.
But the addition of senolytics didn't improve further
significantly the overall survival.
For the old mice, the combination with radiation and immunotherapy
also increased the overall survival, and the addition of
senolytics increased even more this survival.
Then to be closer to the clinic, we wanted to test this
senolytic treatment in an humanized mice model.
Unfortunately, all the immunodeficient mice model that
exist doesn't age well. That's why we decided to
create our own
aged humanized mice model. For that, we used the
C57 black 6 mice that we depleted for immune
cells with an antibody cocktail. And after that, we
intracranially injected GBM43 PDX human
cells into the brain. So we first compared the
survival curve between the young and old PDX model.
And as we can see here, the younger mice live significantly
longer than the older one with a PDX tumor,
which is comparable as what we've seen in the
patient.
Then we treated this old PDX model,
with the standard of care, which is the radiation and temozolomide or the
standard of care with the senolytics.
So the standard of care alone increased the survival
as compared to the control or the senolytics, which is also
what is observed in the glioblastoma patient.
And the addition of the senolytics also increased
this overall survival for at least half of the
population.
So
to conclude, we showed that age-related differences are
negligible in the tumor core of patient resected with
glioblastoma. That senescence is increased in the
extraterminal older brain with GBM.That
senolytic decreased the senescence microglia in the extra tumoral
brain with GBM.
The senolytics improve the survival in older mice with GBM
treated with radiation and immunotherapy or standard of care, which
is radiation and temozolomide. So overall,
adding the senolytic to the tumor cell killing approaches
represent a promising future strategy for older patients
with glioblastoma.
So to finish, I would like to thank my team, all our
collaborators and support, and of course, thank you for your attention.
Okay. Thank you very much. I have a quick question.
So very nice presentation.
Thank you.
So I think in different tumor types, we're seeing this theme of this difference
between the core versus the periphery for different aspects of tumor
biology.
Mm-hmm.
Do you have any...
In the metabolism field, we usually attribute it to differences in
nutrient availabilities. In your context, I'm
wondering, what are your thoughts on it?
Because that was sort of the first thing you found.
We actually wanted to perform metabolomics on those tissue,
but for now we're just looking at the genes in general.
We have a single nuclei RNA sequencing that's supposed to come soon, the
result between the tumor core versus the peri-tumoral areas.
Okay. Nice.
But what we've seen is like about the gene, we don't see
any differences-
Right
... between
an old patient tumor versus a young patient tumor.
So that's why we were like, okay, what can be something else that can
explain the survival? That's why we're looking outside of the tumor,
peri-tumoral, extra tumoral brain.
Thank you.
And remind me,
if I remember correctly from Derek's previous data,
tumors in glioblastoma in aged mice
respond
worse to anti-PD-1, right? Tumors in young mice respond better.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, thanks. I was just trying to remember that.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi. Morillo from Hopkins. Really nice talk.
I was wondering if you guys checked if the extra
tumoral senescence that you see is
only driven by aging itself, or is it
at some level caused by any secretion from
GBM cells from the tumor present in the brain?
Is it like a paracrine effect, or is it...?
What we've seen is
other things were different, but
most likely some senescence genes were different in
the peri-tumoral region. We have
also another,
there was
also microglia genes that were different in the peri-tumoral region.
Maybe that's why we have this link with the senescent microglia.
But otherwise, we did not explore more for now the other
differences.
Did you ever compare to a brain that
did not receive GBM cells?
Like normal-
Yeah
... without the GBMs? Yes, we did. But that
was very different in lot of aspects.
Okay. Thank you.
Fascinating talk. I have a two-part question.
First one is, do you have any thoughts as to why the
senolytics are not able to target this
intra-tumor region? Is it perhaps a penetration issue
for the drug? Because you see better extra tumoral effect with
regards to senolytics. And second part is, when you see
better response as a combination with radiation, do you think
radiation itself is probably inducing more senescence,
and therefore all the senolytics can target that?
Yes.
So for your first question,
we don't really know why the senolytic cannot target
the senescent cells
in the tumor. I don't know if it's something about the
distribution or maybe just because in general,
the tumor show less senescence than the extra tumoral.
And then what was your second
question?
Is the combination therapy seems to work better with the
senolytics.
Yes.
Do you think the therapy itself is inducing senescence?
Okay.
Actually, the radiation by itself induce senescence.
Thank you.
May I just ask a quick question?
When you say that you have very few cells in the
center, the core of the tumors.
Yes.
Is that because they escape senescence or they just never underwent
senescence?
Why we have less senescent cells in the tumor?
Right. Right. So they never underwent senescence or they just
escaped? They just went quickly in there and then escaped
senescence.
That's a great question.
I don't know. I think,
the tumor core by itself is more, as we saw the distribution, is more
malignant cells in general. But then,
it mixed with other cells, but I don't know why the senescent cells
cannot stay in the tumor.
Right. And when you have the radiation, do you still see the same level of DNA
damage in the center, at the core?
Yes, in the tumor, it stay the same level, but increased in
the brain.
Okay. So perhaps, maybe they then never underwent senescence.
Maybe.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much.
So I'm just going to try to wrap up and come up with
some concluding remarks. So I think that there are clearly some
themes that are coming through in all the presentations and
also the work that we've seen in other presentations here at the meeting.
And my takeaway is that aging impacts almost every
aspect of tumor progression and therapy.
And I think that today what we saw from the excellent
presentations, major considerations for immunotherapy, clear
changes in young versus old immune infiltrates, and of course,
generally inflammation. We also saw that in terms of
the metastasis, there's
an aging component of metastatic
progression and clearly contributions by different cells in
the tumor microenvironment.
And I think that we also need to have
more knowledge and information about how local and systemic metabolism
impacts this progression. And then lastly, we saw
using older preclinical models, looks like it better reflects the
older patients, at least in some
types of cancers. And this could be setting up, I think, a change in
paradigms in how we test chemotherapies as well
as targeted therapies. So thank you very much to all the
presenters.
For those of you that are still in the room, we would love to take a photo with you
just to
remember the session. And thank you very much for all the
attendees. Do you have any other comments? Okay.
Thank you very much, all.